good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Wednesday it is hump day
so don't forget to help someone you love
we've got the streis brothers in the
studio so check check check check and
check you might not see my baby boy
Bryce humiliating oh my God are we like
we tried to like Rube Goldberg a little
centerpiece today for the studio if
you're watching on YouTube
and we said if it fell which I didn't
think it would that would be really
embarrassed and we are because so now
everyone can see everyone can see what
we were doing we're low budget noodles
today cute yesterday when you hit hid my
coffee and then but it was hard for me
to drink my coffee so we put this little
thing here to hold up the curd and then
it fell and embarrassed us and that's
not that's crooked sorry
literally that's like you and my wig
maybe you're just okay maybe it's just
like oh
you know motherhood has changed you
if you um oh it's not up yet so we
filmed an amazing gorgeous
um Halloween Vlog we vlogged our whole
weekend like trying um on different
costumes for like stuff with the kids
obviously toast to wean there was a lot
of the creative process behind our
personal family costumes and the
toastoween costume you get to really get
into our minds and see how these
gorgeous looks came together so the Vlog
is ready I'll probably upload it
sometime today be sure to look out for
that and you'll see how Jackie is
definitely off balance because she
botched my way I did like it was The
Botch of a century I know the thing is
we were talking about it last night when
we re-watched the Vlog it's like Claudia
had a very clear idea of what she wanted
so she should have just done it herself
yeah for sure like my whole life I've
been trained just to like know that like
you're more talented than me in certain
things you're more careful like yeah
you're more meticulous detail-oriented
it's like when it comes to cutting a wig
I would never just like raw dog it
myself
should have done that the thing is while
I accept full responsibility and I am
really sorry but it still looks great
yeah
it wasn't me it was viserys I can't oh
my God the cop out of the century I
can't be held responsible for things did
no that's like holding Jamie Lee Curtis
responsible for things Lindsay Lohan did
right no I get it thank you for
understanding also so many big news
announcements but I took my permit test
yesterday and I have not shared the
results because we also vlogged that
experience as well I was thinking I
meant to talk to you about this before
should we like withhold the status of
your test until the Vlog comes out yeah
because it's like what happens is kind
of crazy
okay so I won't say anything more about
that the Vlog will be up in a few days
then and you'll just have to wait and
see on patreon.com
like you know what I need we need to
start being more clickbait I totally
agree we never engage in clickbait and
like cheat ploys but maybe we should no
no like every day even do a group clock
friend crashes car like I'm gonna start
doing that like because we're really
honest we say like you know this is one
of our best episodes we'll say you know
this one's not so great because we are
authentic internet personalities and how
is that working out for us not great so
if you want to know what happened at my
permit test yesterday head to
patreon.com toast in a few days when the
episode is up I just need to edit the
redheads first because that goes live
tomorrow we recorded the new episode of
the redheads last night with the girlies
it was so great to get the girls
together we were getting the band back
together we read Hester by Lori liko
Albanese which is a very seasonal book
because it's like witchy and do you know
the book The Scarlet Letter I mean like
I've heard of it you know easy a yeah
right exactly and it's like American
like literature yeah our letter high
school and so this book like imagines
what happened in the author's life to
lead him to write that book so it's like
a little bit of fan fiction that is cute
it's like um
it's like 50 Shades to Twilight
um you know the idea of you know to
Harry Styles exactly that's next up on
my book reading list except I I told you
guys I started a book club with my
friends like the first meetings on
Monday and everyone's like talking about
the book in the chat I'm like I haven't
even started it so we're flying home
today Jackie is headed to NYC
I see
so I'll read it on the plane if I'm not
too busy just like being in love with
roldini you know of course that's always
so hard I might be busy you might be and
it's really hard to read on a plane when
we have a child a kid but good luck to
you no I'm really excited for you to
read your book maybe I would even join
you in your Pursuit no one can be in a
book club without me like you surfing it
are you still gonna be in town on Monday
do you want to come I won't be but
that's so me you could join in like
virtually it's not the same and like you
should have your own thing like why do I
have to like be like it's a big dope big
sister no because that's us like oh
you're doing something I'll be there I'm
being to you what we are tomorrow oh
you're going to dinner can we come yeah
Nashville for concert can we come but
like when we ask Margo's like no but
like I'm when you ask like of course you
can come we're very like that with each
other like at each other's friends 100
like when I'm hanging out with my
friends they never know when you'll just
be coming to we're a package deal and
that's the thing about like just being
around me it's like I'm full of
surprises you never know what you're
gonna get it's so true she's so
spontaneous I'm not like other girls
she's so unpredictable she eats
something different every single day
I've never really kind of like been the
type of what do they call those
creatures of habit no that's not me
um
foreign
more that more housekeeping so we have
the Vlogs coming we have some in prose
production some will be released today
new episode of the redheads drops
tomorrow and that's all very exciting I
think that's all my housekeeping you
know we've been churning out the patreon
content when we're together which is
always fun yeah and we got a new car oh
my God you guys there's nothing like
vlogging in the car with it's like a
it's a it's a phone mount for your phone
that you can like Mount the phone up on
your windshield or on your desk or
directions but yeah like Uber drivers
it's really helpful for directions and
stuff we use it for vlogging and it's so
premium that's what we did for the mooc
bong so we thought ours arrived and so
we were just living we're being such
vloggers yesterday like it was crazy and
we have a fabulous latter half of the
week plan because we're obviously going
to New York we have some work things
some Mogul Tings but it's also Jackie's
30th birthday so we have like a nice
Shabbat dinner plan we have a gno
planned it's gonna be fabulous yeah I'm
really excited I'm revving up for my
30th it's starting to dawn on me like
the significance of turning third of the
day and like where I was at when I was
20 versus now and like how I spent my
decade so where were you at 20 uh well I
was in college okay and I was just like
not the girl I am the woman I am now no
of course not but like what were you
like The Toasters didn't really know you
at 20. what were you like at 20 at 20.
you're probably like a junior yeah I was
that's kind of crazy you were
rambunctious you were like loud you were
like that girl like kind of like center
of attention not because you wanted it
because like that was like the energy
you commandeered yeah but like pretty
wild lots of drinking like I would say
that's one of the biggest changes from
like then to now and like we really miss
that girl like are you gonna drink at
all this weekend
in yeah in like a measured way like I'm
not no not in like a binge drinking sort
of way no
when do you think the next time you're
gonna like binge drink is
um
it would have to be a time when I'm not
with roles yeah because being like a
hungover mom sounds like the worst thing
I don't know how it can be done yeah no
it literally cannot could you imagine no
no and the hangovers I get yeah no it's
over for me it's game over I'm not
saying I don't understand yeah I get it
yeah wow it's been a Whole Decade a
whole last decade so I feel really good
about leaving my 20s in the past I feel
good about how I spent them like we
built a business right you got married
had a baby like it was an advanced race
advancement on all fronts yeah so I feel
I feel great and I'm excited for this
next decade in part one piece of wisdom
to a 20 year old right now like for what
you learn when in your 20s and what
you're what you now know going into your
30s
oh what would I like tell a 20 year old
self I mean unfortunately like all
lessons have to be learned the hard way
there's nothing that I can say to you
right now that would change anything
you're going to be doing no that's fair
you know so I guess I would just give
some good practical advice like take
your makeup off before you go to sleep
at night and if you you know if you're
feeling crazy use a moisturizer too and
just be careful what you post on social
media yeah that would be like my yes for
sure you can tell anyone that at any at
any age and it still slaps the advice
and you sunscreen yeah
um try not to fry your hair if you don't
have to use a heat protecting spray if
you're going to apply heat
um these are also just good baby pigs in
general you know a way to preserve your
youth
ain't that the truth
um well thank you good life you know you
gotta you gotta figure it out for
yourself yeah just enjoy the ride
and be safe be safe
um well we've got a great show it's
Wednesday which means dear toasters
which is just a truly favorite segment
of ours we've got fabulous stories
Fabulous Girls fabulous Bros and I feel
as though without further Ado it is time
for the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast no it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know link
or the fast five stories that you need
to know
the fast five stories that you need to
know
you know like a can opening yeah yeah
did that translate of course I could see
it smell it taste it
oh it's an excuse for Claudia to do it
ASMR
actually um the last time I did SMR like
nobody could hear anything I don't think
these microphones are really ASMR
approved which is devastating
devastating sure sure
ASMR I'm sure they do okay yeah so let's
get into the stories do you have
anything you want to share with the
group before we do that is so crazy that
you would say that because I actually do
that's so great I mean we're just so
simpatico as stated previously so makes
sense today's episode of the toast is
sponsored by Haya typical children's
vitamins are basically just candy in
Disguise they're filled with two
teaspoons of sugar unhealthy chemicals
and other gummy junk Growing Kids should
never eat and that's why Haya was
created it's a pediatrician approved a
super-powered chewable vitamin While
most children's vitamins are filled with
15 grams of sugar and can contribute to
a variety of health issues Haya is made
with zero sugar and zero gummy junk yet
it tastes great and is perfect for picky
eaters Haya is filling the most common
gaps in modern children's diets to
provide full body nourishment that our
kids need with a yummy taste that they
love they're formulated with the help of
nutritional experts Haya is pressed for
the blend of 12 organic fruits and
vegetables then it is supercharged with
15 essential vitamins including minerals
like vitamin D b12s vitamin C zinc
folate and many others to help support
immunity energy brain function mood
concentration teeth bones and more so
these your mom's vitamins they're really
not and what I um think is so cute about
them it's like it's fun
and obviously good for the kids we love
all that stuff but it comes with like
stickers you can like um decorate
decorate the bottle it's really cute
it's a really fun activity and it makes
like kids feel more involved involved
and it makes them excited about taking
their vitamins of course which is
obviously exciting for adults but kids
aren't always you know uh it's not GMO
vegan dairy free allergy free gelatin
free nut free and everything else that
you can imagine so most of your kiddos
are good to go when it comes to Haya
it's designed for kids of all ages and
it's sent straight to your door so
parents have one less thing to worry
about we have Haya in our home kaler
loves loves Haya they also um she had
the best time decorating the stickers on
the bottle like she was she went wild I
was saving it for like a rainy day for
her and it was so much fun to do with
her we've worked out a special deal with
Haya for their best selling children's
vitamin receive 50 off your first order
if you claim the deal you must go to
highahealth.com toast it's not available
on their regular website it's only
available at Haya Health
h-i-y-a-h-e-a-l-t-h.com slash toast get
your kids the full body nourishment that
they need to grow into healthy adults at
hayahealth.com toast
God bless you thank you what can I say
except God bless you for all the sneezes
and it's not that you spit the thing is
is that I've been here for two weeks and
I haven't even watched Moana because
Kayla's like she's like out of her Moana
era she's now into like a bunch of
different things something different
yesterday I did watch go yesterday I did
watch CoCo I found the plot extremely
difficult to follow I haven't watched it
yet but I'm kind of like saving it kind
of like inside out because I know it's
really good and I want to actually
ingest it not just watch bits and pieces
because I think the message is really
strong they're like you ain't ready for
inside out like I just I know you are
going to love it and in condo I haven't
watched welcome to the family Madrigal
welcome to the family madriga
no I don't like that song we don't talk
about Brew no no
and I think you actually might really
relate to the character of Bruno why
because Bruno is like this family member
who you're not allowed to talk about
obviously because he like left the
family years ago turns out he's been
living in the walls he's been there the
whole time oh interesting it's not like
Kanye says he's a creepy Uncle I mean
he's definitely a little weird he loses
the wall you know
um so there's like something like
definitely not 100 with him but okay
maybe I just won't watch the movie so I
can enjoy the song still welcome to the
family Madrigal
okay thank you for that little Disney
interlude
um our first story Christina Applegate
has done an interview with the New York
Times and revealed that she has gained
40 pounds since being diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis and now struggles to
walk without the support of a crane the
50 year old actress who shared Her
diagnosis initially in August of 2021
reflected on the difficulties she's
experienced while filming the final
season of her Netflix Show dead to me
amid her battle so the new season is
coming out soon and it's the final
season right
um and such a good show she did an
interview with the New York Times and
said this is the first time anyone's
going to see me the way I am I put on 40
pounds I can't walk without a cane I
want people to know that I'm very aware
of all of that so she was filming the
final season and they took a long break
for her to get treatment oh they're so
nice she talked about shooting the last
season and said quote I had an
obligation the powers that be were like
let's just stop we don't need to finish
it let's put a few episodes together
with previously recorded footage and
Christina said no we're going to do it
but we're going to do it on my terms
wow
um first of all dead to me is such a
good show so I'm glad they didn't just
like finagle some ending together
because like thus far it's been like a
really well thought out and like really
good show
um and it's very cool I feel like in
Hollywood like oh you gained 40 pounds
like we're done with you like the fact
that they want to still work with her
and they just kind of like cast her to
the side There's Hope yet for Hollywood
um I also think
perhaps this in this last season there
will be scenes where she's struggling
um I think she said she struggles to
like stand or walk and I I think she
wants to let the viewers know in advance
like if that's what you see this is why
and this is what I'm going through right
now yeah I feel like a lot of people
like I feel like Ms has been a um
like it's been more brought more to the
Forefront like um Selma Blair on Dancing
With the Stars like I feel like I now
know much more I don't know what I
thought Ms was before but I thought it
was like totally like debilitating to
the sense where like you couldn't really
move and seeing people like Dancing with
the Stars and like still going to work
and acting it's very cool I have a like
a really special place in my heart for
Christina Applegate yeah because of
Don't Tell Mom the Babysitter's Dead of
course like I've just loved her for so
long and she's really like she's that
[ __ ] like she is successful like teen
throw heart she's like a literary
teenage heartthrob who then successfully
turned that into like a really long
prosperous career yeah we stand we
really really do and everything she's in
is Stellar Stellar I'm excited for the
new season to come out I hope Christine
is doing well she also is going to be
like doing public press for them
um for the show and it's just like so
sad that she feels the need to preface
everything by being like you know I gain
weight I look different this is why and
it's like she doesn't owe us an
explanation but you know that if she
didn't say anything then the headlines
would just be so nasty be so nasty and
honestly I think that she probably is
giving us a heads up like for her own
sake because to have to deal with like
people commenting on I mean it reminds
me of and it's much worse for women but
just a recent example is like Zac Efron
um showed up to a red carpet like
looking very different like people just
like annihilated him and he's a man so
like it's gonna be worse for a woman so
like I'm sure she did it partially for
herself yes and all and so when people
and someone shows up looking different
like people you know conjecture and come
up with crazy reasons why so I think she
just wants to you know get ahead of it
and
um also promote the new season which is
really exciting dead to me is such a
good show I feel like it's a good bin
show like if you don't watch it knowing
there's the final season is coming out
um I feel like it's 30 minute episodes
it's like not that long but it's like a
really premium it's like nice like
just it's like it has it all it has it
all yeah murder comedy nice house it's
like dramedy tragedy it's got like James
Mars and like most important a Chutney
Linda Cardellini I thought it was you
walking through the front door what
would you how would you feel if your
father was 87 your age
such an iconic movie
chutney
who like does fire rolls fire pipes and
Mad Men she was in Freaks and Geeks but
like to me Linda Cardellini will never
not be chubby of course like the hair
the Plaid power suit I thought it was
you
such an iconic that was a cultural shift
actually
that movie yeah yeah I know that scene
in particular oh no there was some I
think she's my age did you tell you that
she's my age how would you feel if your
father married someone your own age the
whole movie was the shift of course but
like that scene like I remember the
first time I saw it I was like wait
it was chutney
so good yeah Linda Cardellini has like a
good radar for what what jobs to accept
Justin Timberlake should you know take
counsel with these women I actually
think a lot of people should take
counsel with Linda Cardellini I think
they would learn a lot she's really
she's been like she really has managed
to stay at like the top of her game for
a really long time but also like not
become like Overexposed like she can go
to the grocery store like but I'm sure
she makes a lot of money yeah that's the
life yeah she can focus on the art
and as artists we totally get that
totally are you ready for our next story
which is an interesting development in
the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
troll bullying Saga yes Diana Jenkins
identifies the cyber bully who attacked
garcelle's son so real houses of Beverly
Hills star Diana Jenkins has identified
a person who may be responsible for
cyber bullying garcelle's 15 year old
son Jax a source tells page six after
reviewing data obtained under subpoena
from meta which owns Instagram jenkins's
legal team is cracking down on a
northern California resident whose IP
address and phone number were linked to
an Instagram account called at Queen of
the tea
so the source had Diane is committed to
seeing this through an unmasking whoever
is responsible and all parties who were
involved she wants to make sure that she
shares with the public all the progress
that is being made in this case every
step of the way so Queen of the tea was
among the many accounts that Jax
revealed had sent him racially offensive
messages in August they had written some
of the posts that were on Jax's
Instagram stories as like examples of
what he was receiving so
um
now with the potential suspect behind
the important message Diana's attorneys
are pursuing an additional subpoena in
the hopes of producing more evidence
linking the individual behind the
Instagram account to The Wider attack on
garcelle's son this person has seemingly
deactivated their Instagram obviously
now and now we'll have to wait for more
information I cannot tell you how much I
love this I okay there are no words to
tell you how much I love this if true
I love this so much but a part of me
about is a little suspicious about this
just because is it really possible to
subpoena meta and like they'll give you
the IP address of someone who was
bullied like what are the rules about
that well I think the reason well like
obviously if somebody sends me a message
like you're fat [ __ ] like I can't
subpoena meta but I think like the fact
that this was threatening to a minor it
was I think it's technically like it's
not like a hate crime but it's like
racially motivated like I think because
it was such like a Next Level message
maybe a subpoena is possible I thought
the same thing because like girl oh we
could subpoena meta I have a list of
people who's like accounts I need their
IP address no like who else can we
subpoenaed like I I find that very
interesting and I mean you categorize
this attack as like next level but what
does that actually what is that
threshold for getting a subpoena from
meta well I hope it's true one because
anyone who's like ever made a fake
account and like sent a message I saw
like the craziest thing written about
our family recently like jail for you
jail for you like to be to just [ __ ]
make things up or threaten a minor like
jail for [ __ ] you and I hope that
Diana takes this all the way I literally
want to contribute to her legal fund not
that she needs it just so that like let
this be a lesson to anyone who engages
in like anonymous online troll Behavior
like your time is coming your time is
[ __ ] coming I'm getting your [ __ ]
IP address and I'm gonna show up at your
[ __ ] house [ __ ] what are you
gonna do there nothing because this is a
because I don't want to go to jail oh
but I'm going to yell at you and you
know what I am going to do I am going to
take a picture of you because that's
what's most embarrassing yeah no there
just needs to be accountability we were
talking about this last week like if you
want to sling some [ __ ] around like put
your face behind it okay and so that's
what's really interesting I was reading
all these threads on Twitter last night
people were talking about like Elon
Twitter whatever but people were
engaging in like an actual like
interesting discourse not just like uh
elon's like Rich we hate him
um about this thing that Twitter now
wants to do which is
offering a service where you pay eight
dollars a month to be verified now
people are like well that's you know
unfair because yada yada what about like
people who are actually you know famous
and people actually make like a fake
accounts of us like but I think what
Elon was going for which I think is
really interesting is not verified means
that you're famous verified means like
we have your information you're a real
person right so then like Twitter will
just start then
prioritizing conversations and tweets of
people who are verified meaning we know
their name address last name location
social right and I think
I don't know if you should necessarily
have to pay for that because then it's
not fair it's not accessible to everyone
but I think it's an interesting way of
moving forward where it's like
conversations being had on this app
you're really only going to see ones
from people who have been verified in
the sense that like we know who they are
yeah that you're real people and you
want to put like your money where your
mouth is and your face with what you're
saying I actually I think it's
interesting that that was the intention
behind it but I think that that's so
smart and then people who don't verify
themselves who are talking [ __ ] like
you're just gonna be like oh well you're
you're a troll you can dismiss it and
like their content does not it's you
have to search for it it's at the bottom
like right so I don't know if having it
be paid is the best way to do that I
feel like so many social media platforms
apps Services you pay to play so it's
not that crazy if it's an eight dollar
one-time fee no no it's a month eight
dollars a month yeah well if you want to
be like a big wig on Twitter and you
want people to see your interesting
thoughts then that's like it's a
subscription you know know for sure
um I think that there's a really good
concept there I don't I just wonder if
like people who are already verified or
you know celebrities if they don't have
if they wouldn't have to pay they
probably don't which is dumb because
like right that's what people who can
afford it right
um but I just thought like this world in
which everyone has to identify
themselves on social media and engage in
discourse as themselves themselves where
their friends and family can see what
they're saying it's still so brave right
I think that is a very
um interesting potentially like
um
not life-changing changing game-changing
service so I thought that was
interesting yeah
like that this this world in which you
can just create accounts on Instagram on
all these different platforms with not a
single identifying
detail except an email account which
people just make fake email accounts
it's like takes 10 seconds to make a new
Gmail account
um it's really dangerous like it's
really not okay and I think like
Instagram does virtually nothing to you
know and they like do small things and
they think that they solved it like you
can now block an account and block all
the other accounts this person made
that's actually a really good one but is
it based on IP address what's it based
on a device probably okay so make it on
your iPad yeah right like it's it's not
perfect it's not solving no online
bullying but it's a really good step
yeah it's something yeah but still like
they're there's not been anything that's
really going to solve this yet and I I
think that's a very strong idea yeah I
thought that it was really interesting
and people were just dismissing it
because it's like oh eight dollars to be
like a fake celebrity but it's like not
really about that at all and you know
what in the early days of Facebook you
had to have a student email address to
join and like I don't know when those
parameters were lifted and it used to be
for just like college students and it
was high school and college students and
now it's just anything and I think you
can you can be in middle school and have
a big fake account you could be 80. like
everyone has a Facebook but it did start
as somewhere where you had to be a
person no and it was much more it wasn't
you know completely issue free but it
was felt like a lot safer of an
environment yeah we maybe it was the
beginning of all the issues that were
that we're experiencing now but they
weren't as prevalent then
no so I thought that was really
interesting and I think if they do it
it'll be like a a cool
um case study for perhaps other
platforms agreed
um
anyways if true what Diana is sharing I
think that's major awesome also I just
love the idea that like this person like
really thought that like they could send
whatever they wanted because I'm sure
they've done it a million times but
like I just know like they're not
sleeping like this person is so [ __ ]
afraid yeah uh some of the records
obtained from meta were connected to
overseas IP addresses
um however the queen of the t account
was linked to an IP address and phone
number in California and so Diana's
lawyers are looking for more subpoenas
to confirm that this person paid for
internet and phone services tied to
Queen of the team maybe paid for Bots
right right so interesting I like that
Diana's not letting this go yeah I mean
she was real honestly if she didn't
pursue this we probably all would have
assumed but then in the back of my mind
we're like oh yeah that was the thing
Diana did yeah no it she's trying to
clear her name and I know she's not
doing it like for me but I do feel like
enormously grateful because I feel like
this is really this can and should
really
scare the [ __ ] out of people who engage
in Behavior like this yeah and maybe
it's time for them to get some serious
serious help yeah and I think it's great
for garcelle and hopefully you know if
they are able to solve this crime then
they can find a way to maybe be friends
and maybe Diana would even be on another
season yeah maybe I also think this is a
problem within the Bravo space that
needs to work itself out too because
obviously all different corners of the
internet have their own problems Bravo
really seems to have like a fan issue
yeah like I'm saying all Bravo fans by
any means but I'm saying like every
single show
oh like I feel like in recent reunions
they talk about like the death threats
and like it's it's literally a reality
show like everyone needs to calm the
[ __ ] down some people are really like
just genuinely unbalanced and like the
The energy they put into reality shows
so much to the point where they're gonna
threaten the lives of people who they
watch on TV like those like these people
really need help like for real but I
think this is sets a great precedent
yeah it does I love it love it okay our
next story James Corden is having a bad
month
is it James corden's bad month that's
brought to you by away suitcases yes it
is because he needs to go on a trip away
makes suitcases bags and other travel
accessories designed to make moving
through the world a lot more seamless
which is a good thing because travel
makes us better people by giving us
different perspectives so no matter
where you're going you can rely on a
ways range of travel products to solve
real travel problems and get you out
there I mean this couldn't be more
apropro we're flying out today I've got
my way suitcase Ben guts his way
suitcase his is pink mine's black I got
mine his is pink yeah because like I
have a pink and a black one like I was
feeling the black one which meant like
you get the pink one I have a pink and a
dark green one and I was feeling the
dark green one I wasn't feeling like
being pink today no because it's like
November like pink was like my summer
suitcase and now like it's fall spring
joggers men's winter suitcase in like
the way that he doesn't care it's like
he's like yeah sure I'm like okay
um so away offers suitcases bags other
travel Essentials that are made of
different materials like polycarbonate
and aluminum and they come in a variety
of colors and sizes so whatever you're
packing wherever you're going away has
luggage that will make your next trip
more seamless so here's what really sets
the way apart for me it is the um
the interior compression pad that helps
you pack more and the removable laundry
bag it's hidden in the zipper I
literally had my suitcase for over a
year before I knew that it was in there
then you can put your dirty undies in
because we've been talking for years
about how the problem with suitcases is
that there's no place to put your dirty
undies we have to commingle with clean
clothes beautiful clothes you don't
actually watch like every day right of
course if you just touched Dundee so
they also have four 300 360 degree
spinner wheels that guarantee the
smoothest roll even through LaGuardia
which is filled with carpet which makes
no sense to me and I think we should
talk about that they also offer free
shipping and Returns on any
non-personalized order within the
contiguous U.S Canada and the UK plus
there's a hundred day free trial on
everything that they make at a way take
the product out in the road live with it
travel with it get lost with it for 100
days if you decide that it's not for you
you can return any non-personalized item
for a full refund during that period no
ifsens or asterisks
start your 100-day trial and Shop the
entire away lineup of travel Essentials
including their best-selling suitcases
and bags at awaytravel.com toast that's
awaytravel.com
to host thank you so much you're welcome
so James corden's month isn't getting
much better he issued a groveling
apology to Ricky Gervais after being
caught using his 2018 stand-up joke word
for word on The Late Late Show I saw a
video somebody splice together of like
the James and the Ricky it was word for
word a thing from one of Ricky's
specials it's um about like a Town
Square advertising for guitar lessons
and then people getting upset I don't
want guitar lessons I want piano lessons
and it's all about like seeing things on
the internet that you don't like and
just moving on right um and it's
literally word for word and so Ricky
Gervais had tweeted the video of it and
said the bit about the Town Square
advert for guitar lessons is brilliant
crying emoji and James Corden tweeted
inadvertently told a brilliant Ricky
Gervais joke on the show last night
obviously not knowing it came from him
it's brilliant because it's a Ricky
Gervais joke you can all you can watch
all of Ricky's excellent specials on
Netflix
um okay so do I think James Corden sat
down and wrote down a joke he heard from
Ricky gervais's special no a lazy writer
a lazy writer just got fired or a writer
who hates James Corden is sick of being
treated poorly by him and decided to
give him the old one too perhaps I think
that would be very subversive I think
it's a a lazy writer yeah I mean what's
so funny is like you know we put these
you know supposedly the funniest men
ever we put them on TV and they have a
whole team of writers to write them
jokes and they still need to take from
other people and first of all it's never
funny like nobody watches the the
opening monologues of um late night
shows and it's like it's a Courtney dad
jokes it's like not funny
um and there are so many and there's a
whole team of writers writing that for
them people who are like trained
comedians the funniest people in the
country who are writing like it's crazy
and then you have like a super funny
host delivering like right no the whole
super funny line the host got there
because they're so funny yet you're not
gonna write the jokes but like why can't
there be a host who like does his
monologue and like just talks like no
prompter like just says the funny thing
that he's thinking no but like before he
starts the show that's the thing with
late night it's like such an Antiquated
format like this is what Johnny Carson
used to do like you could change it up
yeah it's 20 22. no and it's like there
are so many comedians there are so many
places that we can watch Comedians and
so it's not Johnny Carson where it's
like we're all tuning in right one time
we have options now we have options and
so to to see what they're doing over
there it's just like sad no it's like
embarrassing and it's not very inventive
no and then to to then steal a whole ass
bit
is word for word sometimes I do feel
like especially when you're commenting
on things like in social media or in pop
culture I do think two people can have
the same thought can come to the same
conclusion like create the same joke
maybe it's not always going to be worded
exactly the same but sometimes I feel
like when people accuse other people of
stealing I'm like that's a stretch like
it wasn't the funniest most original
joke anyway and like I could see how
more than one person came to that
conclusion this is literal plagiarism to
one point like one-on-one yes so it's
not the same no it's not the same like
that would be like Ricky Gervais having
said you know you can go on to the
internet and choose not to engage in
things you don't like and then James
Corden saying the same thing and it's
like oh two people think it's a rational
thought and I could see how two human
beings who engage in rational thought
could both come to that one rational
thought but to make this very specific
example and just didn't even Denise it
yeah no he didn't deny that like this
joke wasn't stolen yeah I do appreciate
that he at least didn't blame his
writers I actually think his response
was as good as can be right no I don't
think he stole it himself I think it was
definitely I mean that would mean that
James Corden and all these guys write
their own material and we know that they
don't so he would never do that like
Ricky stuff it's not obscure like you
can find you can stitch
he would never choose to embarrass
himself in this way no but I do think
like his apology not throwing his writer
under the bus who obviously has been
fired and stole the joke um I do think
that's
quite commendable like he took the fall
so I know this is you know one another a
list of things to make James Corden look
bad but for me this actually makes James
Harden like look pretty good ish also as
good as can be when Ricky Gervais like
tweeted the video initially someone said
didn't deliver it like you though I
assume he used he asked to use that joke
and then Ricky said no I reckon one of
the writers came up with it quote for
him I doubt he would knowingly just copy
such a thing or a stand-up routine word
for word like no no of course of course
I'm surprised like nobody else if it's
it I mean I imagine I'm not like a huge
follower of Ricky gervais's comedy like
I actually like him but I don't know his
bits but I imagine if there's a whole
team of writers no one like they all
work in comedy they know comedy
they wouldn't realize one of them is
reciting a familiar a famous bit yeah
maybe they all are working against James
Gordon they're trying to take him down
oh yeah makes a thing so yeah James
corden's bad month continues I really I
wish I wish for him some rest it's hard
going through it like to then go do his
show every day I know that's the thing
it's like other people can take time off
like the the um the internet forgets
because if you become you know do you
take a step back there's more people for
them to make fun of when you're on TV
every single day it's like no no it's
endless yeah yeah
well he is ending his show in like a
year oh so his time is almost up and is
someone else going to take his spot they
haven't said if and who yet but they did
say that he is his next season will be
his final
our next story Adele reveals how we've
all been pronouncing her name
incorrectly this whole time so Adele set
the record straight about her name in a
recent q a with fans in LA to promote
the release of her I drink wine music
video
so someone asked a question and she said
love that she said my name perfectly the
correct pronunciation is a Dale not
Adele
a Dale a Dale yeah uh
hyphen uh Dale Adele
but it's not because it's Adele
but it is it is
I mean I feel like this happens every
couple of years with a celebrity who
like is a household name and then we
find out like their name is Ariana
Grande like right you know what I mean
um
and it's like we all found out Ariana
Grande's name was Ariana Grande and we
still call her Ariana Grande so I don't
know if this is necessarily going to
change the way in which we speak about
Adele yeah um but it's good to know the
more you know the more you know like
it's giving Maj Dijon for me yeah and
one thing about me is that once I have a
pronunciation in my head like I I can't
like I'm physically unable it's crazy
yeah like didn't we find out Rihanna's
actually Rihanna
or did I make that up I don't remember
that okay so I made that one up perhaps
it's definitely possible
um also she's releasing a music video
for I drink wine I can think of that
song without thinking about remember
when you yes me too Claudia when her out
when her tracklist came out before the
album Claudia went through the tracklist
and like did her idea of what I thought
the songs would sound like just given
their titles and when it was I drink
wine she said I drink one one one it
literally sounds like the song like how
does the song go I think it was actually
one of my favorites on the album one
thing about me is that I have not
listened to 30 even once like I don't
know what any of the songs sound like
and I was just watching a tick tock
about this
because what's so funny is like
technically just based based on Purely
numbers alone like Adele is currently in
her flop era
um like her 30 is her worst performing
album since 19.
but it's still like sold me Triple not
even I mean it sold more than midnight
it's like it's a huge seller because
this Tick Tock was talking about like
who the predictions are for album of the
year are going to be and like you really
can't ignore 30 just based on the
numbers
um even though like technically Adele's
in her flop era yeah if you're comparing
her to it yeah to herself but if you're
comparing her to
the average singer-songwriter she's
doing amazing yeah no of course I think
she'll be nominated but yeah
um the prediction for
on Tick Tock
um
who did they say they thought was gonna
win
they were really campaigning hard for
Bad Bunny even though Bad Bunny
otherwise I'm for Bad Bunny
um although this person didn't think and
I don't know what qualifies this person
as an opinion we should give a [ __ ]
about but
um that Grammys has you know kind of
like ignored Bad Bunny that they don't
think like Bad Bunny would be
um but they saw the Renaissance should
be in there they thought Kendrick Lamar
should be in there they shot lizzo
should be in there
um
Luke Combs should be in there is the
album of my year I completely agree by
the way also like Kelsea ballerini Like
That album like
is that album do you know what I mean
yeah I listened to it and I feel like
right now I'm not in the headspace for
it like if if this was like if I was 20
I would be obsessed no it's whimsical
yeah it's just like really light
um but I will at a different like I
don't know it took me by the way when it
came out when I'm getting ready for like
a dinner or something like I'll listen
to it when it came out I was just like
not in that particular headspace and I
was like a little late that's why I'm
talking about it now but now I'm like
fully immersed in the album like it is
an album that feels like an album I
totally get that two things this is
making me excited for end of year music
recap data if I wrapped obviously
Spotify rap usually stops tracking your
data on October 31st but they are
extending it so because of Midnight's
probably because of midnight that's
crazy
huh but yeah I was gonna say like my
data is going to be I don't I have no
idea what it's going to reveal because
like one thing about me it's like I
don't listen to new music like I listen
to the same five like I still love my
2019 Spotify wrapped playlist like I
listen to the same so I don't know what
it's gonna be I think it's gonna be a
lot of Luke Combs a lot of Taylor a lot
of Morgan Wallen because then I think
about where I listen to Spotify and it's
like my Amazon Echo so it's like what do
I listen to in the shower yeah or when
I'm getting ready
it's actually sorry my number one it's
going to be ever more that's really all
I listen to this year
oh true mine is going to be it's a
mixture of me and Harry's music so oh
right probably Luke Combs would be
number one and probably Mimi Webb will
be number two I just like listen to her
song and also like I like songs on
Spotify like five songs a month and I
just keep listening to them over and
over again
um but we've got a lot of Beethoven in
there we've got Elvis I've got a lot of
sagala I think my number one song of the
year is gonna be if I Can Dream by Elvis
actually it's gonna be middle of
somewhere yes it is and then number two
will be if I Can Dream
um and then what else there was one
other thing that I listened to
all that oh I had to put on this white
noise one night and so I put this one
song on repeat and that's gonna be my
number one song of the year no like
Spotify needs to work on the wrapped
thing like if you have kids like
removing all like the cocoa melon like
no I think it's actually a sign of the
times but like I just need to be able to
delete that white noise yeah yeah no
that's not a song no it's not a song I
mean it says it come up as a song or is
it like a podcast
it might be in like a different category
of your data if it's a podcast true
because I don't know how you can make a
song that's an hour you know and no it
wasn't it was like three minutes and it
was over and over oh it's a song it's my
song of the year how exciting
okay our fifth and final story some
super exciting news
some of the Queen's personal effects
will be going up for auction yes
mementos of the Queen's War Her
Majesty's driving permit and photos of
her working as a mechanic you should get
the driving permit I know I don't know I
was looking through and they didn't have
um prices and she had to go to London
like I think we need to get on a plane I
think we need to auction they're going
up for auction alongside a 1950s
Petticoat from our girl cute I need the
driver driver's permit yeah that's what
we need that's what we need if anybody
gets it if you want to share I want to
apologize to the podcasters Theo snoring
so loud if that's what you've been
hearing I keep trying to like move him
to like no I don't I think the smooth
sounds of Theo snoring are calming okay
okay I just wanted to let you know like
it's not anything in in your office or
your car like it's Theo yeah
um also her undergarments are going up
that's very nice
um auction 1500 pounds and then there's
some military era momentos that are set
to reach 20 000 pounds but the queen
never held a driver's license fun fact
well it's a permit she no no I know but
so she got her permit she was permitted
to learn but then she never had to get a
license she never had to she never did
like but she drove all the time oh she
always showed herself think of that
Queen being a criminal
driving without a license it's like a
literally a C-Class felony yeah
it's bad well bad Queen but maybe it's
fine because she had a permit and there
was always an adult in the car no but
she used to drive herself around no I
know like Balmoral no but there was
definitely like a security guard in
there like she was probably never alone
in the crown like and Philip
in that movie that I just watched the
Queen She Drives alone well it's a movie
and also it's her property right so
everyone could [ __ ] off everyone can
[ __ ] all the way off yeah
um okay we have to buy the permit like
Theo stop yeah so there's no
no price too high you know what we need
we need a Queen Elizabeth the second
Museum it could be like one of these
traveling museums it can start happening
of course of course of course but it
should come to New York it should have
like tons of Queeny effects and I think
that would be a really great way to
honor our girl
um well I think another great way to
honor our girl would be helping you know
other queens in Deer toasters that was
the segment the Segway of the century
she would love that she would love to
see Queens you know fixing each other's
crowns yeah I don't know if you guys
know but the queen was a big toaster and
huge she did say that dear toasters was
her favorite segment so
for her
we do this and we honor her with this
segment which is sponsored by Origins
the pioneering nature-infused skin care
brand that has elevated gift sets that
will surprise and Delight everyone on
your holiday shopping list Origins
create transformative skin care and
naturally derived ingredients to
noticeably noticeably improve how your
skin looks and feels Origins has a long
history of commitment to our planet by
reducing waste and caring for our
natural resources all of origin's
holiday gift sets are plastic free
recyclable and sourced from responsibly
managed forests and for every tree
harvested new trays are planted to date
the brand is planted over 2 million
trees around the world so you can feel
good about the gifts that you are giving
this season from Origins so if you have
anyone in your life who's like difficult
to shop for
or someone who's just really into Beauty
who's really into the environment
Origins is a great place to shop because
they have all these different gift sets
um so if someone who's like really into
skin you can do the Fantastic favorites
which is their six best-selling
essentials from cleanser to moisturizer
and their size to go wherever the
holidays take you they also have the
mask this way which is a five mask
starter kit the all for youth which is
uh plant description Essentials to
cleanse and pump
um you can help them say hello to
younger skin and then you can also do
their all-time Essentials kit which is
their all-time Essentials a day and
night Radiance boosting gift for the
glow getter on your list get this for
the 20 year old in your life who needs
to start moisture so when they're 30
they'll thank you at Christmas for that
gift you got them all those years ago
that is such a great gift like a five
step gift set here's all this here's
everything you need and also you can get
like individual products stocking
stuffers yep the toast gift guide
continues and this is a great one
Origins is toast gift card approved
um so you can get the origin gets the r
Origins gift sets today available at
origins.com that's
o-r-i-g-i-n-s.com those gift sets are
available at origins.com check it out
toast tested toast approved origin
skincare like is that bad you know okay
ready for dear toasters or advice
segment where we do our absolute best to
try and help people yes if you guys ever
want to write in it's deertoesters
gmail.com try and keep it brief even
though today's we have a long one to
start but like it's worth it okay okay
and the girly needs our help okay dear
Jackson Claude first I would be RDH if I
didn't acknowledge how beautiful
sounding and smart you both are thank
you for providing us with premium
content day in and day out love you both
wow thank you so much thank you you're
so welcome okay I need some help I gave
birth to the most precious baby boy this
summer he's a pee jump and is the first
grandbaby on my side normally this would
be a huge deal and he would instantly be
the center of attention among my family
right wrong here's the thing the thing
is my dad and stepmom decided to adopt a
puppy a month after my baby was born and
ever since that day my son has been
overshadowed by this dog I send photos
of the baby's first doctor appointments
I got a text back with a photo at the
vet
oh you think your baby is teething my
puppy just lost two teeth it's a cute
pick of the baby in the stroller but
here's the puppy on our walk today this
is her dad and stepmom yeah every time
she send the picture I didn't know if it
was her in-laws or no her dad and or her
kin no it's her kin and it's the first
grandbaby on the her side got it got it
I complained about our lack of sleep
once and they started talking about how
hard crate training has been I mean
every conversation circles back to the
dog it is so awkward and cringy to me
this makes me not want to send any
photos or share updates about my baby
which makes me so sad not to mention
they've been so busy puppy training that
they haven't really asked about how the
baby is doing on their own not to be
dramatic but I feel like they're missing
out on the most exciting times of his
life do I say something about how this
is making me feel to ask my sister with
calling them out for being super
annoying or just try and ride it out and
hope it gets better love a mama toaster
who's sick about he who is sick
overhearing about her parents dog that's
so crazy no that's like something like
kind of diabolical that like a 20 year
old would do not like a grown ass man
yeah at least it's giving you you know
what it's giving I don't know anything
about it's giving evil stepmother
Meredith Blake right but she didn't say
that like it's the stepmother leading
the chart no but she just did say like
dad and stepmom so like not me like you
know villainizing the Stepmom right no
of course and of course part of my
advice would be like go talk to your dad
one-on-one I'm glad to hear that you
have a sister and yeah and she like you
can talk to her you can talk to her
because you know if the these two were
your only family and they're not like
getting excited that would be so
disheartening that would be so
disheartening I think that you're
totally justified in feeling sad about
this and if you do feel like a lot of
the dog Fanfare is coming from evil
stepmother
um maybe talk to your dad one-on-one and
be like I'm so excited but see the thing
is like I actually don't think it's
coming from the evil stepmother like the
dad that was my production excited about
a new dog yeah
we don't even know if the Stepmother's
evil like maybe the stepmother stepped
in when this girl was two and has been
like a real mother to her like we don't
know you know right right we're right
like I was just projecting like what
I've known about stepmothers from the
movies maybe like you've talked to both
of them and just say it like I totally I
think tasking the sister like you're
[ __ ] busy [ __ ] like you're busy I
think if your sister went over there and
be like hey I went to Rachel's house
last night and she was like so
overwhelmed with a baby and she was just
like really upset feeling like nobody
cares like she had a baby and everyone's
like obsessing over the dog so I feel
like we should all make a conscious
effort like that's what you do like when
someone has a baby like they're really
vulnerable they don't have time to like
talk about their feelings with everyone
like I think testing the sister is a
great job as long as the sister handles
it like a pro and it isn't like obvious
that like this is like a setup you know
yeah hopefully stepmother doesn't listen
to this podcast
um yeah I like that too like this is a
job for this is what sisters are for but
also just like prepare yourself for if
they continue to be disappointing and
to to like d to divest to de-invest from
caring about like what their opinion and
sharing pictures in the stroller like
find a different group chat to send
those pictures send them to us who care
about you and we'll be excited put them
in the toast after dark Facebook group
like we'll be excited yeah we will be
excited chosen family like send them to
your sister send them to your friends
like don't keep setting yourself up for
disappointment if after your sister
talks to them it doesn't get better no
because this is hella [ __ ] rude yeah
like the more I think about it like it's
literally child ass behavior from a
grown ass man and a grown ass woman and
honestly I'm pissed yeah sister
send the sister
and if nothing changes bye like
seriously bye yeah we have a lot of like
Mama related ones today yeah you don't
send pictures and see how long you got
before they ask yeah yes withhold
withhold the cuteness die best hijacking
Claudia I need some objective advice
while keep this concise I am 35 with
children
I need some objective advice so I will
keep this concise yes I am 35 with two
boys a four-year-old and a one-year-old
and a husband we have two embryos left
both girls and my husband says that he's
done part of me agrees but the other
part of me really wants a girl and for
context my hubby really pushed for boys
so he already got what he wanted and if
it matters we found out the gender of
our embryos before having the first two
right
who gets the final call here we can't
really have another one if we're both
not on board but I want a girl help and
please keep Anonymous sincerely a
toaster who wants a mini me no I mean
like your man's got what he wanted like
it's time for you and also like you do
all the work when it comes to childbirth
like it's it's ultimately it's a
decision you both have to make but
ultimately it's your call no but she
asked like who gets the last word the
woman the woman gets the last word like
women are like pushing children out of
their vaginas when the roles are
reversed and the man really wants
another kid and the woman doesn't like
oftentimes the woman gets the woman has
the one who has to carry the woman's one
who has to give birth like it's a lot on
the woman so yeah it's a decision that
you guys should
talk about no and like when a man wants
more children like it's so sweet like
it's so nice but it's literally not your
call yeah and I think that this is what
you want then
but the thing is you have to want it bad
enough to want it enough for the both of
you yeah and to like can bring him to
your team you know because if you're
like I wanted a little bit like that's
not gonna convince him but if he sees
you're so excited you want a girl so
badly like it's everything you've ever
wanted then like of course that's your
husband and he loves you and that's what
you're gonna do yeah but also I I'll
like I want you to do whatever you want
but I want to say there's something like
extremely cool about being like a mom of
just boys like we were just met this
woman in your neighborhood who has like
so many boys and she was like the
coolest [ __ ] I'd ever met like I was
really taken by her like I kind of want
to be like I want to have like like five
boys like I think there's like kind of
something sickening about it you know
what I mean and I think about all like
my friends moms who I know who like have
all boys and I'm like they're so cool
you know yeah so just think about like
there is something really cool obviously
like girls want to have girls but
there's something like kind of sickening
about being like a mom of boys and then
like these boys grow up into like big
huge men it's like yeah [ __ ] I did that
you know and like you can you can be in
charge of like how these men enter the
world and like how they treat women like
it's just like it's very powerful you
know yes but I would also say like aside
from the gender like wanting a girl when
we have boys and he wanted boys like do
you want another baby do you want to
bring another human into this world do
you want to Foster another life
that's something that you have to answer
for yourself and then you either have to
want it bad enough to like get everyone
on board because it can't be like half
in okay so by the way like if you you
know God willing one day bro like have
more kids like do you have a preference
for what you have next I I don't like
you're so girly so obviously like a girl
would be nice before like when I got
pregnant the first time before I found
out the gender like I really did want a
girl
um and when you found out I was a boy we
were like a little disappointed like
it's okay you could say like like a
little if I had to have chosen right you
would have chosen I would have chosen a
girl thank God I didn't have to have
chosen because I'm obsessed with being a
boy mom no totally and so many people
who and I announced like my pregnancy
and the gender so many people message me
they're like I'm one of four girls I
wanted a girl so badly but I have a boy
there's nothing like having a boy and
it's and it's so true it's so different
that there's something so special about
having a boy and like the connection
between a boy and his mom no it's so
true like so some of the best boys out
there that I know like love their moms
and that's why they're the best because
they love their moms and they respect
women so it really it's been amazing and
so if you had to choose like do you now
want to have like one of each or like
you want to try and be like at a
strictly boy house like if you had to
have a preference well I don't want to
say because then like what if then I
have any other kid and it's not what I
said and they'll always be like yeah
we'll delete the episode okay here's the
promise we'll delete the episode if you
end up with the opposite of what you
wanted okay
I'm not saying I could just see it okay
will you tell me afterwards of course
yes
um well best of luck to you and at the
end of the day remember it's your call
but like Jackie said it bad it's like
you have to want it enough for two
people because like to convince him like
if there was something that my husband
wanted so badly more than anything in
the world like it would make me want it
too yeah but if you just wanted a little
bit like it's not gonna happen yeah no
no and also like like this is why I
think about it like you could be done
having kids like isn't that what you
want to be done right
like I feel like I would want to be down
you know it's like I can't wait till
like like I want to have kids I'm gonna
love my kids I have my future kids see
this like I don't mean it but like I'm
excited to be done with the part of
having kids and just like being like a
human being again raising kids you know
like I wish I was at that stage I look
at like other people on social media who
are like done I'm like oh my God you did
it like it's behind you I'm so happy for
you I know but they look at you like
it's all in front of you and like those
those baby years like that they can't
get back like those were the best of
times oh my God that's so sweet what a
great shift in perspective shifting
perspectives with Streisand our third
and final good morning I am in a mom's
Facebook group for our local area and my
sister is a nanny for a family that is
also in the Facebook group they don't
know that me though or my name wait
sorry start again I was just thinking
about the last one I always happens to
me I am in a mom's Facebook group for
our local area and my sister is a nanny
for a family that's also in the Facebook
group okay but the families in the
Facebook group doesn't know about this
sister yeah recently the mom that my
sister nannies for posted in the group
saying that she was unhappy with their
Nanny AKA my sister she said she wasn't
doing enough educational activities with
her kids and she's looking for a new
nanny to start ASAP but she is not told
yet the nanny the former Nanny my sister
is not a part of this group and
therefore doesn't know that they are
looking to replace her she loves this
family and the kids love her do I tell
her that the mom posed to this or do I
let her find out on her own in a couple
of weeks time I know she'll be
devastated but I don't know if it's my
place help a loved but cons but confused
toaster obviously you tell your sister
like this in this job market like she's
got it you know get proactive she's got
to start sending out resumes not even
that tell her to start upping the
educational content no by the way like
give her the answers to the test exactly
this literally sounds like The Nanny
Diaries where it's like you're not
talking to Grayson in French like yeah
we'll have to get him in Au Pair no like
I think this is obviously a super
awkward situation but I think that you
should tell your sister not in like a
gossipy way or like a you know your done
way but like I S they're so I don't want
you to be upset she wants more
educational stuff for her kids like ramp
that up and like she could be happy yeah
actually that that's true I didn't think
about that I thought about her like
getting out of jobs like dumping the
family be like oh you're gonna dump me
I'm gonna dump your first [ __ ] but no
that's true she could still Salvage the
job go get some books like yeah just be
like I saw these amazing things like I
was watching Miss Rachel or whatever I
was like I was watching nachio they were
talking about this amazing exhibit at
the mat like you didn't be okay if I
took Sarah yeah like I don't know what
educational what the ages are and like
what materials the kids should be
ingesting at this age like get some
workbooks right and start making it in
an educational environment no you have
like some people could write in the
comments like good things
to do in the educational realm for kids
that would really impress your her
employer no I feel like you've really
gotten like a an unfair Advantage now
like you know what your employer wants
and you're going to give it to her
before she even asks yeah love that love
that for you good idea thanks your
advice was on point today mine was like
a little all over the place no your
first one you got the first one right
yeah you got the last two though thank
you thank you to everyone who wrote in
to Dear toasters which again is always a
safe space you can write in we'll keep
it Anonymous you can change people's
names we would never blow up your spot
and you could write in about anything
today was very family heavy sometimes
it's more friends heavy sometimes it's
more relationship heavy I like these
ones me too they really made me think
um and that email again is deertoesters
gmail.com try and keep it
as brief as possible just like the need
to know information like don't get
caught up in the details because if it's
too long we can't read it um because I'm
too lazy so that's our show tomorrow's
show will be in New York City please go
easy on me tonight we have a fabulous
end of the week we're headed out to to
the big apple right now so thank you so
much for listening to the toast the
Monday Morning Show where we deliver the
fast five stories that you need to know
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcast anywhere podcast we
found so that's Spotify iTunes ditch
Republic video I have redo guest books
all the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the toasty but five
star review about how wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an incredible
hump day don't forget to hump someone
you love and we'll see you tomorrow bye